It's great to welcome to the program today,
Steven Hassan, who is one of the leading authorities
on culture
and mind control.
He's the founder of the freedom of mind resource
center and also author of the book the cult
of Trump, a leading cult expert explains how
the president uses mind control.
So first of all, it's great to have you on.
Um, I think maybe a good place to start is
when we talk about mind control in the way
you talk about Donald Trump using it.
You know, last week we talked to someone who
researched CIA mind control programs.
That's not the same type of mind controlled
that your talking about.
Right?
So actually in my book I talk about MK ultra
and CIA mind control research when I'm doing
a historical like how did we get to where
we are here?
Yes.
Um, and so it is very relevant also because
the CIA in the early days of this, uh, of
this research I should say, the research about
because of communist brainwashing, which the
term was coined in the 50s and military intelligence
was sending people to S what are the communists
doing to get people to renounce their allegiances,
to turn in their family members and friends.
So people like Robert Lifton, Margaret singer,
Edgar Schein, Louis and West are the four
big people who when I was first the program
from the Mooney is I read their material and
met with them and they said, Holy mackerel,
what you're describing in the Moonies is so
much more sophisticated than what we study
in the fifties.
And they were very encouraging me to learn
more and share with them.
Get back to your question.
Yeah.
The MK ultra, a part of what they were studying
along with LSD was hypnosis.
And they do have a section in the book about
hypnotic, uh, methods, uh, indirect methods
and also the use of language to deliberately
elicits powerful emotional States and vivid
visual descriptions in people's minds.
The use of repetition over and over and over
again to enforce a black and white all or
nothing good versus evil mindset.
Um, and in my book I really tried to cover
the basic ground of, of making the case, uh,
that, that Donald Trump acts like a stereotypical
cult leader has the malignant narcissistic
characteristics.
Does the pathological lying, doesn't have
the empathy, never takes responsibility.
Oh, you know, I go through all of the patterns
as well as cause people are saying, I have
friends, I have relatives who are really smart.
They're very educated, but they're totally
into Trump.
They're totally captivated and think, you
know, that he's the answer to God or the answer
to all the life's problems.
And that's exactly the mindset I had when
I was in the moon calls in the 70s.
Yeah.
I mean, given that experience, what do you
see that it is that pulls people that seem
very intelligent?
They often seem more intelligent than Donald
Trump himself.
What is it that is happening?
Is it, is it message, is it personality?
Is it tactics?
Like what?
Or is it a combination of [inaudible]?
It's a combination of all of the above.
So the first thing is that I want to state
is that my work involves trafficking victims,
uh, PO people in political cults, therapy
cults, religious cults, even cults of personality
where the person is really subjugated by another
person, afraid to make them upset with them,
that they may want to get revenge, harm them.
So the, the, the, the point for me with Mike
destructive mind control is you can't have
that applied in a negative way without the
use of deception because no one, no intelligent
educated person would say, I want to be deceived.
I want to be exploited and harmed.
I w I want to, I want to have my critical
analytic mind dismantled.
Um, and when it comes to, you know, how I,
how I behave.
Um, so it's, it's a bi-directional process
between the influencer and the influence E.
however, in the United States where we're
dealing with, uh, digital media, we're dealing
with Breitbart news, Fox news, uh, religious
broadcasting that work, the Trinity broadcasting
network.
And one universal that I see is that people
who are only listening to one partisan viewpoint
and getting all their information that fits
into one of the four components of mind control,
which I call information control, especially
if that information is propagandistic doesn't
care about what factual and what's provable.
Uh, and that appeals to emotions, particularly
fear.
And I talk about the universal mind control
technique of phobia indoctrination, which
in the mind of somebody undermine control.
They can't imagine, you know, criticizing
the leader or leaving the group and being
happy and fulfilled.
They can only imagine a disastrous world with
this, this deep state cabal that, that that's
filled with traffickers, you know, that, that,
that are going to destroy America as we know
it, etc.
So that makes a lot of sense.
When it comes to some of the just set general
public followers of the president, I'm curious
whether when you look at the way that a lot
of the Republican party at least claims to
have fallen in line with Donald Trump, are
they, uh, subject to the same sorts of, of
influences?
Or are they just sort of playing a role because
they've decided it's Polete politically expedient
and advantageous and they're not really falling
for it?
So that's a very good question.
And the answer is, I don't know.
We'd have to kind of analyze person by person
and involvement by involvement.
But what I did learn when I was researching
this book this year is that there are a very
powerful cultic groups that are influencing
Donald Trump.
And I believe giving him instructions.
It's these groups that actually have millions
of followers that are his base.
These are air quotes that are his base.
Um, and that these folks are following their
leadership, who's saying, we need to follow
Trump.
And the minute those, those leaders, uh, change
their mind and decide that Donald isn't following
God or isn't doing, uh, God's will on earth,
they're gone.
What groups are those?
So in my book, I have to start with the obvious,
uh, Putin and, and, uh, the Russian, um, uh,
influence is definitely influencing, uh, Donald
Trump in my, in my research as well as all
the Russian emigres around the world who are
listening to Russia TV.
They're also S it directly and indirectly
implementing that.
But then I get into a secret of cold called
the family or the fellowship.
The two bestselling books by Jeffrey Charlotte
were written about this called, it's been
around in the United States for 80 years.
It to, was created in the cold war era to
fight godless communism, to create a group
for Jesus, except it's not the traditional
understanding of Jesus.
This is an appeal to elitists, people who
are powerful, wealthy, uh, individuals, and
they've been manipulating, uh, the United
States government policy domestically as well
as, as foreign for 80 years.
Uh, there's a wonderful docu docu series that
Jeff Charlotte did for Netflix called Emily
that I would highly recommend that.
So Michael Pence was recruited into the family
by Chuck Colson who was a convicted Watergate
felon and he w and Pence was involved with
bringing in the cabinet members.
So this is a direct influence as well.
Then I get into Opus DEI, which is a Catholic
right wing secret of cult, um, that it appears
attorney general William Barr is uh, involved
with and can help explain why he would not
be representing honestly the molar report,
the substance of the Mueller report or it
is lecture at Notre Dame last school recently
about the need to get more Christianity into,
uh, American, uh, ma members' mind, citizens'
minds.
Then I go into one of the scariest groups
and this is a conglomerate of organizations
I call the new APIs Dalik reformation or I
should say they call it that.
These are groups where the leader says there
are an apostle or a prophet who gets direct
revelations from God.
They typically speak in tongues, they cast
out demons, they do faith healing, they stay
up all night praying and, and fast for long
days.
And, and they're very high tech and there's
at least 10 million Americans.
And when the media talks about Trump's base
and said, calls them white evangelical Christians
in my opinion, I know white evangelical Christians
and their I gassed at what is being promulgated,
um, from the white house and their policies
against immigration for example.
And this is this, it's this cultic group that
I'm very concerned about because they've been
told that Trump is a sinner.
Yes.
But he's like a King Cyrus figure and God
is using him to advance the agenda of, of
breaking down the separation of church and
state in order to impose, um, what Christian
White Christian view on America.
And then we get into all rights and we get
into libertarian.
Sure.
Yeah.
Which we're more familiar with as sort of
a more well known political groups.
So, and the somewhat limited time we have
left, you were deprogrammed what is it that
works to deprogram people from cult beliefs?
Because what we do seem to know is that hammering
them over the head with facts does not seem
to work often appeals to values backfire if,
if, uh, or sometimes fail all together.
What are the successful sort of characteristics
of deprogramming?
Right.
So first of all, I, I kind of flinch a little
bit with the term deprogramming cause humans
are not computer.
Oh, I used it because you had used it.
That's the term the media likes to use.
I was truly deprogrammed in 1976 after a near
fatal van crash, they took my crutches away.
So I was being held against my will.
Um, you know, and I've gone on to do voluntary
interventions, but the key is you're absolutely
right.
You can't say anything directly critical against
the leader, the doctrine or the group.
Because the triggers thought stopping, which
is one of the mind control techniques makes
people defensive.
It actually makes them feel persecuted and
more, more deeply embedded.
So the best thing to do is to, is to create
a warm relationship with the person.
Say, I respect you, you're intelligent, you're
educated.
Help me understand how you came to have the
beliefs that you have now.
When did you first hear about Donald Trump?
Did you watch the apprentice where you are
a fan or did you ever hear of him before he
started running for the GOP and and and essentially,
and this was happened with me in the moon
call is I was sure I wasn't brainwashed.
I was a hundred sure, but I was open to hearing
about Chinese communist brainwashing techniques.
So I was open to going through Lifton's a
criteria.
I've developed a model called the bite model,
which stands for behavior control, information
control, thought control and emotional control.
You go through the components about this other
group, not the one you're in communism or
or traffickers, traffickers groom and indoctrinate
people to be sex slaves or labor slaves.
And then you, then you ask the you, you tell
them, look, the only way to really reality
tests is to actually talk to critics and former
believers and really reflect over your own
experience.
Are you blocking automatically any critical
thought against the leader, the doctrine or
the group or not?
And the truth is, in my experience, I've been
doing this work for 43 years, is that nobody
wants to be a fool.
Nobody wants to be conned.
Um, and, and when they see, you know what
I believed what I believed based on what I
was told, what my experiences was, but now
I have more info.
Yeah.
I can change my mind and I'm not a bad person
for changing my mind.
I can go, yup.
You know, Darren moon isn't the Messiah.
You know, I was brainwashed those in the two
and a half years.
Yeah.
That's super interesting because it combines
number one, the starting from a point of empathy,
which former white supremacists have described
to me as extremely useful with some of the
techniques.
Um, honestly that, that reminds me of Dale
Carnegie's how to win friends and influence
people, which is let people believe, lead
people to believe they are deciding to change
their mind even if you are sort of in some
way participating in opening the door for
them to find that truth themselves.
It's an interesting combination of tactics.
Yeah.
It's not a Dale Carnegie technique.
It really comes from my own experience.
Uh, and, and it's genuine that I really do
believe that people deep down inside want
to know the truth, absolutely want to be manipulated
and allied to, they will respond to respect
and love
and, you know, convinced me.
Yeah.
And there's also like an element of what this
guy, I'm Anthony Magna Bosco called street
epistemology, which is just having conversations
with people about, uh, getting them to talk
about how they came to believe the things
they believe without necessarily challenging
any particular belief head on.
Right.
So the, the key in terms of my methodology
and I've written three other books before
I wrote the cult of Trump.
Um, the, the, the key is really educating
people about what we know about the human
mind.
That what we've learned about social psychology,
how we, for example, are our prime to follow,
um, our, that we identify with, even if they're
saying the wrong size line that we can see
with their own eyes.
Two thirds of everyone doing the Asch conformity
study starts agreeing with the wrong answer
or people following who they think is a legitimate
authority figure might start admitting or
administering shocks to the point where they
may electrocute another human being who's
in the room and their hearing screens help
me my heart, but they keep following the authority
figure.
It's understanding social psychology that
we're human beings, that our minds can be
influenced and also understanding that your
nap not a bad person if you've been in programmed
with bad beliefs.
We've been speaking with Steven Hassan who
is one of the leading authorities on cults
and mind control.
Make sure to check out the book, the cult
Trump, a leading cult expert explains how
the president uses mind-control.
Stephen's such a pleasure having you on today.
Yeah, thanks so much David